e66 le on peut passer un message au
président chinois xi jinping si nous
écoute qu'est ce que tu lui dire hey toi
et moi j'ai rien à lui dire parce que
américaine est bien évidemment je je je
suis je suis en fait de tout coeur avec
donne a changé le fbi à washington
il faut savoir en fait que certains
c'est un coup d'état
et bien évidemment tout ça on va arrêter
juste pour en fait rend les gens plus
pauvres plus pauvres est resté en fait
il nous reste en fait que les riches il
faut savoir qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui aux
états unis les gens perdent leur rupture
vers leurs maisons font la queue pour
pouvoir nourrir leurs enfants et c'est
très très grave c'est pas si vous avez
ce nom alors c'est vrai ça m'a fait
drôle elle dit détruire millions de
chômeurs elles sont mignonnes vendeur
est tenu en main il n'ya pas d'être
comme en france en a c'est ça que non
c'est vrai alors il faut savoir il faut
savoir cyril et la france et emmanuel
macron que tous les gens aux états unis
ne peuvent plus payer leur maison ils
dorment dans leur voiture ils ont 400 $
par semaine incroyable paye des taxes
donc c'est un vrai coup d'état c'est la
guerre c'est en fait qu on veut c'est un
coup monté par la chine non gouverner
alors la parole ni pouvoir virer de
nanchang